- On s'en va à l'autre bout
- Lundi matin, Cité-de-la-Santé
à Laval.
- Allô!
- Dre Montigny nous plonge
Le taux d'occupation dépasse
les 120 %. Un problème plombe
les efforts des soignants :
occupent un lit sans avoir
besoin de soins. Ces patients,
pour Niveau de soins
alternatifs, attendent une place
à domicile.Dre MARTINE MONTIGNY,
dir. adjointe, CISSS de Laval
nos structures, parce que c'est
en les désengorgeant qu'on peut
consacrer le temps nécessaire
ont besoin pour être soignés.
- Les patients NSA utilisent
plus de 2000 places en milieu
du Québec. Leur proportion
atteint des sommets inégalés
depuis le début de la pandémie,,
bien au-delà de la cible
de 8 % établie par le ministère
de la Santé.adj.
soins infirmiers, l
- On a des enjeux pour amener
parce qu'il faut attendre que
la COVID soit term des
vacances, puis on a la pénurie
de personnel. Ça nous amené
à certains lits au niveau
de l'hébergement.
- Parmi les régions les plus
au sommet avec un lit sur cinq
occupé par un patient NSA.
BENOÎT HEPPELL, chef de larierie
- À 20 % c'est un peu intenable.
- La liste d'attente pour
une place en CHSLD en Estrie a,r
atteindre environ 400 personnes.
- Par exemple, certains vont
attendre un CHSLD un peuvont ate
une unité spécialisée dans
un CHSLD et peuvent attendre
des semaines, voire plusieurs
- Mais de nouvelles solution
émergent au CISSS de Laval.
- Niveau d'alerte 2, 125 %tion.,
on avait 19 demandes d'hospi
- Des réunions quotidiennes
servent à décidersortir esortire
d'un tableau de bo
créé de toutes pièces.
ROUA HAMMOUD,infirmière clinicie
- J'ai des CHSLD q
en éclosion, fait que ça aussi,
ça va pe
les patients qui sont NSA.
- Imagine demain
matin, chacun des hôpitaux
du Québe
ces gens-là, il n'y a plus
de place.de place.de place.de p.
- Ça fait quand même un petit
Je pense qu'on est en attente
isme d'accès à
l'hébergement, une place
- Sur l'unité réservée auxpatie,
un nouveau poste a été créé
d'étranglement.
Mais vous votre rôle?
- C'est de les sortir,
où est le problème, pourquoi
ils sont pas capables de sortir.
- Si elle tire les ficelles
pour accorise surtout le retour
à domicile pour éviter
de surcharger les ressources
en hébergement.
la sortie.
- Oui? Demain?
- Probablement.
Vous êtes contente?
- OK, c'
- Ici Jean-Philipp